we've still got a few weeks until the
big Nintendo switch presentation which
means the rumors and reports are still
flying I'm Tony and this is your powered
up game spot news update
ventureBeat has two sources reporting
that the switch will use Nvidia's
Maxwell graphics technology and not the
newer Pascal architecture this means the
system would clock in over 1 teraflop of
performance but that's below the
standard ps4 and Xbox one and for
reference the ps4 pro clock set at 4.2
teraflops and project Scorpio is
projected to hit 6 the sources say this
is due to Nintendo's desire to get the
switch out as soon as possible
perhaps performance power was a
compromise the company had to make
speaking of Nintendo you can check out
game spots top-5 3ds games of 2016 right
now and tune into our game of the year
livestream on Tuesday December 20th at
10 a.m. Pacific we'll have all sorts of
special guests and prizes for you there
and for all the latest Nintendo news
you're already in the right place
you